now welcome to the CEO playing gender
men from from the Netherlands to sleep
referring to young team on snow name in
there but it's probably not the money i
doubt that he's playing on lunches okay
the bogo again on oops let's play
something else try fun okay in english i
instantly try to get something going
here against the pole on see phone yeah
you it's it's quite usual that Dwight
sacrifices the point i'm only not sure
about this exact position yeah okay what
else because of afore i wasn't sure
there was I was a bit concerned about
the directive form and before but I
could have taken so it's not a big
problem
ok so he intends to do to give this
check here
completely fine maybe Bishop f4 mmm
Bishop f4 you should perform yeah d5
opens the position while not being
developed not really a logical move okay
yeah I think you can just take them and
term maybe and maybe I can do that and
this is maybe a solo km yes
thought maybe i can i can still somehow
make d for work but it's probably not
not the case
Oh
yeah I know I didn't see you move it's
just the most chaotic move that I have
that came to mind at this position night
c7 King d8 night AAA takes on f4 maybe i
can i can i can get get to this okay i
didn't see that at all but i don't know
yeah b6 ever seen before Queen a six
yeah I need to play more water 12 okay
this was the idea I'm not a bad idea 97
winning the Queen and the rookie saying
and wow
yeah this is also good now which I can I
can I can take with the Queen I forgot
about that yeah it was it was winning in
any case black resigns yeah what a
disaster yeah you shouldn't really open
the position while you are materially
down this is not not bad for like I but
d5 is just insane it's probably losing
straight away yeah i forgot about Bishop
before which is rather embarrassing so
how to how to play this well besides
that it's clear that it's not d5 um yeah
this is my opponent played this right so
it's a bit big anyway
yeah Midas better maybe I like a six a
bit more check make weenie five or
something I it's a big compensation
that's a big compensation this kind of
position White has an excellent
compensation now taking the c4 pollicis
is slightly risky of course check mail
iam here's something else he's not
immediately threatening to to to to wipe
me out maybe the computer suggests this
move is very strange one idea could be
f6 and get the night to have seven tap
strange white has a very good
compensation here but d5 was just a
completely completely suicidal
absolutely no way to defend that alright
thanks for watching